13:37 a net with the third has just had
his French lands confiscated normally
such a conflict would be resolved by an
English king acknowledging that they
held these lands as a subject of the
French King well not this time Edward
the third would try the different tactic
of declaring himself to be the rightful
king of France instead his claim came
via his mother
Isabella which the French dismissed
because inheritance wasn't matrilineal
naturally Edwards claim at the beginning
of a war the Hundred Years War couple of
quick facts first the war actually
lasted for 116 years and second the war
wasn't continuous and there were many
years of peace between the three main
phases of the war so at first
Edwards struggled to raise the money for
an invasion so had to delay any military
action until 1340 the year he formally
declared himself the King of France this
year saw the first major battle of the
Hundred Years War the Battle of sloughs
this battle involved the English
requisitioning merchant ships an
outfitting them for war
these ships then sailed for the French
Navy stationed its Loy's the result was
the destruction of the French fleet in
England securing the channel after they
said word landed in France but nothing
much really happened on either side
because war is expensive and no one
could afford it the truce was declared
but it didn't last you to the death of
the Duke of Brittany in 1341 Brittany
was semi-independent to France and both
sides back rival claimants to the Duchy
Edward landed there in 1342 and took
this land before another truce was
signed the next year negotiations
towards a permanent peace between
England and France broke down mostly
because Edward didn't want peace in 1345
the war resumed but the English weren't
very successful barring some victories
in Gascony the next year so the main
english thrust when Edward took a large
army and landed here in Normandy Edwards
advance was not meant to capture and
hold land but was instead what is called
a chef or chez which is when an invading
army essentially set everything on fire
Edward moved north before King
Philippe's much larger army caught up to
him and the two sides clashed at the
Battle of Crecy cress he was not only a
surprising English victory but it was a
decisive one seeing many French Nobles
in the king of bohemia killed inhaler
ferrous from english and welsh
longbowmen after this victory Edward
marched north and laid siege to Calais
capturing it the next year Calais was an
extremely important gain for Edward
because it provided a gateway into
France at the shortest crossing point
from England making future campaigns
cheaper English good fortune wasn't
limited to France as the king of
Scotland who had been at war with
England since 1332 was captured by the
Archbishop of York at the Battle of
Neville's crossed just outside of Durham
the feeling of celebration would be cut
short by the introduction of the Black
Death and
13:48 which was kind of terrible the
destruction wrought by the plague meant
that no major military campaigns could
be undertaken by either side for many
years in 1350 King Philippe died and was
succeeded by his son King John the
second there was some skirmishing and
piracy over the coming years and both
sides tried to sue for peace but neither
could agree on
Edward owing homage in 1355 Edward the
Prince of Wales better known as the
Black Prince due to the armor he wore
launched a devastating Chevrolet and
decimated French lands he was confronted
by King John who had a much larger army
of poitiers in 1356 the battle here is
one of the most famous English victories
in history mostly because the French
King was captured thus continuing the
long streak of Kings who were caught
John being terrible capturing King John
was a huge bonus for the English and the
ransom demanded was huge
French luck worsened when the country
descended into civil war and rioting
meant the King John's ransom couldn't be
paid thus invasion in the end the French
agreed to the Treaty of Bretton in 1360
which ended the first phase of the war
could the Edwardian phase this treaty
gave Edward all of this land in return
for Edward dropping his claim to the
throne and lowering John's ransom King
John would never be released since in
1364 he died in London and was succeeded
by his son Charles v peace between
England and France would be broken in
1369 when King Charles called the Black
Prince now the Prince of Aquitaine to
Paris the prince refused and so war
under Charles the French did much better
with an early victory in 1370 at
Pantheon shortly after this the Black
Prince became unwell and returned to
England in 1372 this second phase of the
war called the Caroline face or the
English territories reduced from this to
this by 1376
this year also saw the Black Prince die
in the next one Edward the third died as
well the throne passed to Wed Woods
grandson who was crowned Richard the
second at the age of 10 3 is after this
Charles to fit the France died and was
succeeded by Charles the sixth who was
only 11 so having two children ruling
two kingdoms at war was not a recipe for
stability many know who's vied for
dominance over the new monarchs but in
England Richard Uncle John of Gaunt
acted as a stabilizing force
gaunt was an accomplished general and
was also married to the daughter of the
king of Castile through whom he claimed
its throne he attempted to take up his
claim in 1381 with the help of the
Portuguese whom England had made an
alliance with in 1373 which was
confirmed by the Treaty of Windsor
incidentally this treaty is still in
effect today making it the oldest active
Alliance in the world
ultimately John of Gaunt was
unsuccessful in taking the
still Ian's thrown him by 1389 he was
back in England political divisions
along with the financial pressures of
Worman the richard ii made peace with
the french which would last for the rest
of his reign richest reign was
consistently played with issues
surrounding his nobility who had
stripped him of significant power france
also had issues with king charles the
sixth who was prone to bouts of madness
because of Charles's condition a Regency
was established which led to a power
struggle between the duke of burgundy
who controlled these lands and the duke
of all yan who controlled these back in
England it was regaining some of his
lost powers and ended up exiling John of
Gaunt son Henry Bolingbroke in 1398 the
next year gaunt died and Richard
disinherited Henry which was a bad idea
Henry returned to England to reclaim his
seized lands most of the English
nobility sided with him and Richard was
overthrown there was some debate over
who would succeed Richard but ultimately
Henry succeeded him as Henry the fourth
the first monarch of the House of
Lancaster but as far as the Hundred
Years War was concerned Henry wasn't
very important suffice to say that there
was some fighting but it was sparse and
also the English kept losing despite the
civil war in France Henry the fourth
died in 1413 and was succeeded by his
son Henry the fifth who is one of
England's most famous kings
Henry was willing to make peace with the
French providing they gave him this land
shockingly they said no and so war it
was in 1415 Henry landed in Normandy and
seized Harfleur before moving north to
Calais before he got there Henry was cut
off by the French army and they clashed
this battle the Battle of Agincourt is
known for being one of England's
greatest military victories the English
were heavily outnumbered but Henry's
army was 80% longbowman the French
casualties were massive in the French
nobility was devastated by the deaths
and imprisonment of many of France
leading officers Henry ding continued
his campaign afterwards and sail back to
England with his hostages Henry returned
to France in 1417 this time setting out
to conquer France entirely and have
himself crowned king because France was
still undergoing civil strife the
English were able to capture most of
Normandy except for rwan which fell in
1419 1419 was an important year in the
war because it's what the Duke of
Burgundy assassinated on the orders of
the French aired the dolphine of France
the Duke successor Philippe sided with
the English in declared his support for
Henry as the King of France along with
many other French Nobles this was the
final nail in the coffin for the French
and resulted in the 1420 Treaty of tois
this stated that Henry was to be the
region and heir to the French throne
that Charles's children were to be
disinherited and that Henry would marry
Charles's daughter whom he had one son
with in 1421 also called Henry not all
of the French accepted Henry is
resistance to him continued with both
the English and French winning victories
Henry was not just a conqueror managed
to overcome many challenges at home once
that challenge was the Southampton plot
this saw several nobles attempt to
overthrow Henry and replace him with
Edmund Mortimer a cousin of Richard the
second this plot was forward before it
could begin in earnest although they
would have had trouble anyway since
Mortimer didn't want to be king Henry
also made great efforts to increase the
use of the English language in
government another issue which any the
fits had to deal with was the continuing
rise of lollardy a religious movement
which just like the church is an
institution Henry saw holidays a threat
to stability and so found a clever way
of stopping Lala's from continuing their
protests burning them alive
John Oldcastle is the most notable of
those burns since he was an old friend
of Henry's Henry returned to France to
strengthen his position in 1421 and it
was there that he suddenly died of
disease the following year two months
later Charles the sick died and so the
infant Henry the sick was supposed to be
crowned the King of France as well in
1428 in an attempt to crush dissenters
the english laid siege to ollie on but
the defenders were relieved the next
year by an army which was special for
one simple reason it was partially led
by a woman this woman was Joan of Arc
commonly known as the maid the English
was soon after crushed at the Battle of
patay many French Nobles switched
allegiance to the Dauphin who was soon
after crowned King Charles the seventh
in 1430 Joan of Arc was captured by the
burgundians and handed over to the
English since she'd claimed to receive
visions from God she was tried as a
heretic and in 1431 she was burned at
the stake in 1435 the Pope attempted to
bring the war to an end but both sides
refused what did happen during the
negotiations was that the Duke of
Burgundy made amends with Charles the
seventh thus England's most important
ally had deserted making the French
significantly more powerful after this
the French recovered the initiative and
recaptured large waves of land in 1444
truce was signed which was supposed to
last until 1450 however the English
broke the truce in 1449 by launching a
military action in Brittany this gave
the French the excuse they needed in the
next year they retook Normandy and
shortly afterwards crushed the last
English army at the Battle of forming Yi
or the remain now was Gascony in Calais
in the former would not last much longer
the killing blow came in 1453 when an
English army was destroyed at the Battle
of Casti on this was mostly due to the
advancements in the use of gunpowder
weapons and superior French tactics for
many historians Castillo marks the end
of the Hundred Years
but be aware no treaty was signed in its
immediate aftermath England's
territories had gone from this to this
and back to this in 116 years or the
remain was Calais in the Channel Islands
the reason why this is often considered
the end of the war was that there was no
longer any realistic chance of England
retaking France the ambition to do so
would however remain until the 19th
century the Hundred Years War has many
important legacies it fostered a sense
of English identity one centred on the
English language which began to replace
French is the language of the ruling
class whilst the French victory did not
kill off any English ambitions to the
lands in France it does mark the point
in which England starts to be viewed as
an island nation the Hundred Years War
also marks a period of immense restraint
by the French he managed to go this
entire period without naming a single
King Louis but much like the piece this
wouldn't last I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching there
are some books in the description below
if you'd like to learn more
you